[Music]  damn turn around from what you got you a  pal pal juggernaut take it up a notch oh  my god Wow let me take a heist music  [Music]  [Music]  it's some kind of monster wait that's  not a mobster that's a man wearing  shoulder pads there's only one super  villain whose fashion sense is quite  dead dating  Balthasar flat I want every agent on the  scene immediately  hey mr. C are closing fast yes wait why  what did you call us  Brucie you know GRU and Lucy push  together Brucie ha ha I like it but not  a lot I don't like him getting away  that's what do you think  hello haha what about that oh wow Oh  girls dance fight hmm this is not over  day to you happy birthday dear day  and happy birthday  who's bad boot ah no you seen that  before  no with that skirt you should probably  stop staring with Laurie cos creepy  though too late  [Music]